nadège abderrazak vous êtes en compagnie
de sébastien chenu du rassemblement
national
c'est sa député du rassemblement
national alors dites moi sébastien chenu
à ce que vous allez votez pour ou contre
ce plan de déconfinement présenté à cet
après-midi par edouard philippe les
députés du rpt à son tour national
voteront contre ce plan de déconfinement
ce plan déconfinement il repose sur des
mensonges et repose sur des incohérences
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous votre
encontre des mensonges parce que le
premier ministre ne dit pas que
l'organisation mondiale de la santé à
nous demander demande aux pays de
protéger de tester massivement les
populations depuis le mois de février
il nous raconte linverse de cela et
surtout des incohérences sur les
transports des incohérences sur l'école
des incohérences sur les masques sur les
tests et donc par conséquent nous
voterons contre ce plan de déconfinement
que nous contestons qu'est ce que le
rassemblement national aurait fait de
mieux à ce qu'il aurait fallu lui confie
n'est resté confiné encore plusieurs
mois dans plusieurs choses et nous
l'avons proposé il ya bien longtemps
déjà
il fallait d'abord fermer les frontières
et les contrôler et pas un mot
d'ailleurs sur les frontières avec le
plan déconfinement d'edouard philippe
vous pourrez venir à paris si vous
habitez observable que vous ne pourrez
pas venir à paris si vous habitez la
bretagne
il faudrait évidemment poursuivre une
politique de tests massif des français
toute personne testée révélés positifs
pour être isolé or là le premier
ministre parce qu'ils n'ont pas le
nombre de tests disponibles ne préconise
que de tester simplement des personnes
qui ont qui déclenche des symptômes
on sait que dans cette maladie 85% des
personnes n'ont pas de symptômes
donc on ne ferait pas la même chose
évidemment nous l'avons déjà proposé et
puis le reste on est dans le grand flou
le tracking aucune mesure développés
concernant les pme les écoles dont on
refile la gestion au maire qui
reposeront sur le volontariat
tout ça est très incohérente tout ça est
en fait à l'opposé du discours
catégorique que nous aller raconte
emmanuel macron sébastien chenu merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je sais
que vous êtes attendus ailleurs merci
beaucoup donc député du rassemblement
national et bien qu'ils critiquent
également lui aussi y est la gestion
gouvernementale de cette crise sanitaire
liée au kobus 19 alors que derrière
dans l'assemblée nationale le débat se
poursuit entre le gouvernement et puis
les croûtes parlement merci beaucoup et
nadège nadège abderrazak devant
l'assemblée nationale